herzlichen dank für die einführung nach
dieser kurzen pause ich dass sie ganz
herzlich zu unserem vortrag begrüßen
mein name ist barbara lenz tage und ich
werde gemeinsam mit meinen kolleginnen
elizabeth funktion katharina assen ihnen
heute fast über das erklär video
erzählen beziehungsweise darüber bleibt
als leistungsnachweis angesetzt werden
kann und dann auf unser praxisbeispiel
angehen dazu beginnen möchte ich kleine
ganz provokativ frage aufwerfen nämlich
ist es an der zeit die traditionellen
prüfungsformen an der universität zu
verwerfen diese frage die wir uns
überlegt sondern wird schon seit einigen
jahren in der wissenschaft diskutiert
und die ist heute gerade aufgrund der
durch die kommune kann der nie
entstanden völlig veränderten
rahmenbedingungen für die universitären
lehrerbildung aktueller denn je meine
kolleginnen und ich werden heute eben
erklärvideos als alternative
prüfungsfragen vorstellen und dann ihre
eignung für den universitären einsatz
diskutieren
in der universitären ausbildung der
nehmen leistungsseite hier eine zentrale
stellung ein also sie bestimmen die
qualität der lehre weil sie zum einen
auf einfach auf die lehre wirken aber
auch auf das lernen der studierenden
wirken indem ich das steuern und für die
folgenden theoretische grundlegung wird
das konzept das constructive allein ein
zahn gezogen
von diesem konzept liegt die konstrukt
konstruktivistische lernklima b zugrunde
das heißt wir gehen davon aus dass das
lernen von studierenden selbst gesteuert
wird und in zweiter punkt ist hier noch
wichtig und zwar mit dem rahmen des
konzepts postuliert dass eben die
kompetenzen deren entwicklung innerhalb
der lehre kassieren soll dass die dann
tatsächlich auch sich in den
leistungsnachweisen wiederfinden und da
gibt es eine ganz klare zeitliche
abfolge also erst nachdem klar ist
welche kompetenzen will ich denn
eigentlich im rahmen meiner der
veranstaltung fördern kann ich mir
überlegen welchen leistungsnachweis
ähnlich weil die sich damit wieder drin
finden müssen
ja welche kompetenzen sollen lehrkräfte
erwerben also was soll innerhalb der
leistungsnachweis es sein in der lehrer
profession forschung wird in den letzten
jahren vereines modell von bauernbund
herangezogen und dem modell liegt die
annahme zugrunde dass ich einfach diesem
und kompetenzen im lauf des lebens
entwickeln durch erfahrungen durch das
lernen das heißt also wir an der
universität sind in der lage zur
entwicklung dieser kompetenzen beider
arten
und in der vielzahl von studien konnte
nämlich auch schon gezeigt werden dass
diese kompetenzen die von bauern und
gunter formuliert werden sich tag
formuliert wurden sich tatsächlich auch
auf
leistungen der schüler das lernen der
schülerinnen und schüler aus wut
was sind diese kompetenzen
profession wissen multinationale
orientierungen und überzeugungen
beziehungsweise werthaltungen sowie die
selbst regulativen fähigkeiten die
bilden den kern dieses modells wobei die
besondere bedeutung des profession zu
wissen von diesen autoren amazon konter
immer wieder hervorgehoben wird
dass profession wissen weder sich in
pädagogisches wissenbach wissenbach
didaktisches wissen
organisations wissen und beratungs
wissen
im namen der motivation ahlen
orientierung sollen interesse und
selbstbezogenheit überzeugung gefördert
werden nach die überzeugungen der
angehenden lehrkräfte sollen sich
entwickeln jandy beziehen sich vor allem
auf die strukturen die ziele des
jeweiligen 8 bei sony auf die genese des
wissen
die selbst relativen fähigkeiten also
die fähigkeit zum engagement oder zu
distanzieren und berlin folgen da jetzt
nicht eingehender berücksichtigt weil
die fähigkeiten sehr stark an die
praktischen erfahrungen mit bobic sind
wie wir so im rahmen des studiums er
nicht machen
die studierenden seien also im namen
ihres studiums die möglichkeit haben
diese dimensionen zu entwickeln bzw die
in dimensionen innenliegenden
kompetenzen zu entwickeln und diese
kompetenzen sollen dann inhalt der
jeweiligen prüfung sonst sein das heißt
wir müssen unsere prüfungsformen da hin
überprüfen ob im rahmen dieser prüfung
form tatsächlich auf diese kompetenzen
geprüft beziehungsweise gefördert werden
dabei ist klar dass multinationale und
orientierungen und überzeugungen nicht
wirklich geprüft werden können und
sollen aber sie sollen durch die leere
und auch die art der prüfung von
gefördert werden zu 27 klasse überlegen
welche prüfung song ist denn motivieren
zusätzlich motivieren sich mit den
inhalten auseinanderzusetzen
nachdem wir uns jetzt vor allem mit den
inhaltlichen leere opposition zu
spezifischen anforderungen beschäftigt
kann man nicht nur nun im blick auf die
form aktiven ansprüche an
leistungsnachweise waffen
zusätzlich gibt's ja ganz ganz viele
verschiedene kriterien die man so an den
prüfungsformen heranträgt also zum
beispiel die ganz klassischen route
kriterien bei der labilität oder auch
die ökonomie
diese kriterien
neben diesen zahlreichen kriterien die
wir auch haben schauen wir uns trotzdem
an und erhalten wir auch für zentral
aber wir haben vier zudem vier kriterien
ausgewählt die sich eben gerade für die
angehenden lehrkräfte als besonders
relevant erwiesen haben
den stirn und muss zwei zum beispiel zum
studieren muss zum beispiel zu beginn
der lehrveranstaltung klar sein nach
welchen kriterien und maßstäben die
leistungsnachweise beurteilt werden und
er spielt gerade bei angehenden
lehrkräften die zentrale leute als sie
selber später überprüfen und bewerten
werden und da die freiheit einfach nicht
ganz besondere bedeutung hat
durch den fokus auf das forschende
lernen in der lehre soll den
studierenden die keiner mehr an
wissenschaft ermöglicht werden
dabei verstehe unter forschende lernen
nicht nur so aufwendige büros forschung
zu anderen tatsächlich
wie mir diese strategie zur bearbeitung
komplexer probleme diese produkte dieser
einzelnen forschung zu kappen können
danach als leistungsnachweise verwendet
auch das feedback ist von zentraler
bedeutung
zum profitieren zum einen die lernenden
aber auch die länder von also geben die
studierenden den dozierenden zu lehre
und zur prüfung feedback können die
studierenden das lernen und das leeren
auf die studierenden abstimmung und auf
der anderen seite haben die studierenden
die möglichkeit sich selbst besser
einzuschätzen
wir lernen anzupassen
im späteren berufsleben als lehrkraft
spielt die kombination eine ganz
wichtige rolle also in meinen unter den
lehrkräften selber auch aber auch mit
externen ansprechpartnern und daher
sollte die bereitschaft zur kooperation
bereits in der lehrer ausbildung
gefördert werden die prüfungsformen
sollten also dahingehend überprüft
werden ob die studierenden tatsächlich
die möglichkeit haben mit ihren
kommilitonen zusammenzuarbeiten
und ebenfalls unter dem stichwort der
kooperation kann eben die frage
beantwortet werden ob die
leistungsnachweise tatsächlich
gegenüber den kommilitonen oder einem
weiteren personenkreis öffentlich
gemacht werden wenn man jetzt so an
diese klassische leistungsnachweise wie
ist der mean arbeit denkt dann stellten
die studierenden oftmals viele viele
stunden arbeit in dieser die
seminararbeiten und zu sehen die kontur
der dozent unser anspruch ist es dass
quasi diese
leistungsnachweise auch so einen
öffentlichkeitswirksam den charakter
haben das sei das heißt dass die
kommilitonen auch von ihren mitstudenten
quasi lernen können
nimmt man jetzt beide bereiche zusammen
also oben diese inhaltlichen
anforderungen die sich aus dem modell
professionelle handlungskompetenz
dagegen und unten diese informativen
anforderungen dann ergibt sich zwar
nicht unser arbeitsmodell nun mit dem
modell möchte hier kassierte überprüfen
ob sich erklärvideos als alternative
leistungsnachweise
eigenen oder eben mit diesen
leistungsanforderungen nicht gerecht
werden und dazu werden wir zunächst mal
skizzieren wie wir unser seminar
aufgebaut haben
ja genau also in unserem seminar dient
das erklärvideos leistungsnachweis und
unser seminar das ist ein seminar für
grundschullehrer an studierende aus der
didaktik des sachunterrichts und des
seminars in der sozialwissenschaftlichen
perspektiven des sachunterrichts zu
bankern und setzt einen schwerpunkt auf
das politische lernen das seminar
gliedert sich in drei phasen in phase 1
werden grundlegende fachliche inhalte
zum politischen lernen in der
grundschule erarbeitet in phase zwei
recherchieren die studierenden zu
konzepten also zu dem vorwissen von
grundschulkindern im bereich des
politischen lernens und in phase drei
geht es darum die in phase eins
erarbeiteten fachlichen inhalte für
grundschulkinder gut erklären zu können
die erklärungen so ein anknüpfen an die
b konzepte die in phase zwei erhoben
worden
diese erklärungen sollen im erklärvideos
für die kinder zugänglich gemacht werden
diese videos dienen wie gesagt
gleichzeitig als leistungsnachweis für
das seminar
was sind eigentlich erklärvideos unter
der bezeichnung erklärvideos werden
filme verstanden in denen inhalte
konzepte und zusammenhänge in kurzer
zeit möglichst effektiv erklärt werden
und die erklärvideos die werden
überwiegend von den erklärenden selbst
produziert und
warum könnten erklärvideos gerade ein
passender leistungsnachweis in der
lehrer innen bildungs seien es ja so
dass gut erklären können eine der
wichtigsten kompetenzen einer lehrkraft
ist nach bauma darunter wird gutes
erklären als kriterium für guten
unterricht und gesehen
und da das erklären im unterricht aber
einen sehr komplexen prozess beschreibt
können erklärt videos als variante einer
vorbereiteten erklärung eine möglichkeit
darstellen wie lerne gute erklärt mit
erklärungen bereit stellen können aber
auch wie schüler innen sich
vielschichtigen inhalten nähern können
haben ja einleitend ausgewählte
anforderungen an leistungsnachweise
dargestellt nun soll eben überprüft
werden inwieweit das erklär video als
alternativer leistungsnachweis in der
lehrerinnenbildung diese anforderungen
erfüllt
ich möchte gern mit der anforderung der
transparenz der maßstäbe die
studierenden müssen wie gesagt wissen
nach welchen kriterien sieht bewertet
werden
die inhaltlichen anforderungen an das
erklär video werden vor allem der phase
eins unseres seminars kommuniziert es
handelt sich um die inhalte der
sozialwissenschaftlichen perspektive im
sachunterricht die später im
erklärvideos abgebildet werden
durch die auseinandersetzung mit den
inhalten soll profession wissen durch
den aufbau einerseits von fachwissen
aber auch durch den aufbau von
fachdidaktischen wissen generiert werden
ebenso werden in phase 2 und 3 maßstäbe
erarbeitet und kommuniziert die im
erklär video anwendung finden und
bewertet werden
ein zentraler maßstab der mit den
studierenden erarbeitet wird und der in
den leistungsnachweis und seine
bewertung mit eingeht ist die qualität
der erklärung selbst
neben der fachlichen richtigkeit die
durch die erarbeitung der inhalte
bereits vorbereitet wurde sind weitere
qualitätsmerkmale einer guten erklärung
relevant
würden durch das projekt falke an der
universität regensburg belegt
ein kriterium ist die adressaten
orientieren die erklärung muss so
gestaltet sein dass die lebenswelt und
das vorwissen der rezipient innen
berücksichtigt wird in unserem fall muss
sie also auf die kinder zugeschnitten
sein
darüber hinaus sind die merkmale
sprechen körperausdruck sowie
sprachliche verständlichkeit selber ein
weiteres merkmal ist die
strukturiertheit
strukturiert meint dass ein roter faden
im verlauf der erklärung zu erkennen ist
dass es sich transparent schrittweise
aufbaut und sich nicht in
nebensächlichen details verwirrt
sondern ist die kriterien einer guten
erklärung und nehmen den merkmalen einer
gruppen erklärung sind natürlich für die
qualität von erklärt videos weitere
merkmale relevant ein zusätzliches
merkmal als die angemessene gestaltung
das muss man also bei der gestaltung von
erklärvideos beachten hier ist eine
minimalistische gestaltung anzuraten
damit der cognitive durch den einsatz
von medialen effekten nicht zu hoch wird
außerdem muss eine ausgibt angemessene
darstellungsform gewählt werden die
eingesetzten grafischen oder
schriftlichen repräsentationen
gegenstände animationen oder experimente
sollen das gesagte illustrieren
empfehlenswert sind möglichst wenig
ablenken der elemente so dass der inhalt
im fokus stehen kann die angemessene
länge eines erklärvideos für
grundschulkinder beträgt zwei bis sechs
minuten so lange videos werden häufig
abgebrochen
außerdem beeinflussen ästhetik und nur
zur freundlichkeit das emotionale
befinden der patienten genauer gesagt
deren and win situation
das nächste merkmal ist die
visualisierung oder besser gesagt die
umsetzung passender
visualisierungsmöglichkeiten
dabei ist einerseits die visualisierung
zentrale begriffe zu beachten
andererseits ist auch die aufbereitung
der relevanten informationen durch
geeignetes bildmaterial oder modell
darstellungen wichtig
empirisch belegt ist die bedeutung
interaktiver elemente beim lernen mit
videos interaktive elemente das können
zum beispiel pausen seien die lernenden
zeit geben das erlernte zu verarbeiten
aber auch sinnvolle anschluss aufgaben
geht die vermittelnde information in
einer verständnis aufgabe aufgreifen
können solche interaktiven elemente
darstellen
kommen wir zur nächsten anforderungen an
einen passenden leistungsnachweis in der
lehrerinnenbildung den forschenden
lernen
in dem die studierenden die ein phase 2
unseres seminars selbst die play konzept
der schüler/innen erheben versuchen sie
sich in einer ersten eigenständigen
forschung es informiert sich über den
forschungsstand zu nehmen von drei
konzepten entwickeln forschungsfragen
und führen auch die erhebung
eigenständig durch um die zuvor
geschnittene adressat nur den tieren gut
umsetzen zu können sind die kenntnisse
von bei konzepten wichtig und durch die
literaturrecherche zum thema play
konzepte und die eigene erhebung kann
das erklär video passgenau auf eine
schülergruppe zugeschnitten werden
auch diese erforschten und
recherchierten play konzept der aus das
seminar phase 2 erweitern das
kommissions- wissen der angehenden
lehrkräfte
eine weitere anforderung ist das
feedback also inwieweit bekommen denn
unsere studierenden im prozess der
erstellung des leistungsnachweises die
möglichkeit sich feedback einzuholen
die studenten bekommen ja bereits
während der arbeit an den erklärvideos
zu mehreren zeitpunkten rückmeldung zu
ihrer arbeit durch kunst dozent innen in
phase eins weil die studieren sich
zunächst in form einer sache analyse mit
den inhalten auseinandersetzen diese für
kinder erklären möchten und diese
erkenntnisse werden dann mit der
dozentin besprochen und die überlegung
überarbeitet nachdem die studierenden
die play konzept von den kindern erhoben
haben passen sie ihre erklärungen an
diese frau konzepte an
und dann erstellen sie im anschluss das
drehbuch für video auch hier erhalten
die studierenden rückmeldung eine
weitere feedbackrunde durch die
kommilitoninnen und die dozentin der die
studierenden ihre erklärvideos
präsentieren ermöglichen ihnen eine
finale überarbeitung der videos
kommen wir noch zur anforderung dass
leistungsnachweise kooperationen
ermöglichen sollen damit sie auf die
spätere arbeitswirklichkeit als
lehrkraft vorbereiten die studierenden
entscheiden in unserem seminar selbst ob
sie das erklärt video in einer
kleingruppe also dem einsam mit ihren
kommilitoninnen erstellen möchten oder
alleine eine kooperation ist
ausdrücklich erwünscht
ein teamergebnis ist jedoch kein muss
im seminar sind die studierenden aber
dazu aufgefordert immer wieder gemeinsam
eigene und fremde arbeitsergebnisse zu
diskutieren außerdem erhalten alle
studierenden einsicht in die arbeiten
wieder kommilitoninnen zum beispiel
während der arbeitsphasen aber auch in
einer abschlusspräsentation
und genau diese transparenz also die
möglichkeit nicht nur das eigene produkt
und den eigenen prozess bewertet sehen
sondern auch über die ergebnisse der
anderen teilnehmer innen in den
austausch zu kommen das bewerten die
studierenden in unserer ersten
evaluation des erklärvideos als
leistungsnachweis als besonders positiv
auch in den feedback und
produktionsprozessen an wertvolles
produktions wissen bei den lehrkräften
aufgebaut werden
wir kommen also zu dem vorläufigen
ergebnis dass erklärvideos durchaus das
potenzial haben eine alternative zu
klassischen
leistungsnachweisen in seminaren in der
grundschulpädagogik dort zu stellen
nicht zuletzt wegen der angesprochenen
doppelfunktion also auch der
vorbereitung auf die
arbeitswirklichkeit der lehrkräfte
allerdings gilt das natürlich hier
einige limitationen zu berücksichtigen
ein wichtiger punkt ist die ökonomie die
einführung in die methodik kostet
seminar zeit die man sich nicht
unbedingt nehmen kann oder möchte
zudem ist der aufwand durch die
intensive betreuung und das feedback für
uns dozierende relativ hoch und in bezug
auf die kooperation angemerkt werden
dass die eigenleistung der studierenden
bei einem gemeinsamen produkt nicht
immer sichtbar wird
zudem ist einschränkend anzumerken dass
diese theoretische überlegungen bisher
nicht empirisch geprüft wurden erste
hinweise aus unserer pilotierung im
sommersemester 20 21 haben gezeigt dass
die studierenden neben der sinnvollen
kooperation vor allem den einblick in
die arbeitsprozesse und ergebnisse ihrer
kommilitonen schätzen
deshalb lässt sich vermuten die das auch
so dass provisions wissen der
studierenden erweitert werden kann sie
sind aber lediglich erste hier hinweise
da unsere schichten wie bei der
reduzierung lediglich 30 studierende und
fasste
und daher wollen wir im wintersemester
im rahmen einer studie mit einer
größeren stichprobe die wahrnehmung der
leistungsnachweise aus sicht der
studierenden erheben und so erste
empirische erkenntnisse gewinnen
herzlichen dank wir bedanken uns für
ihre aufmerksamkeit und jetzt stehen wir
natürlich gerne für rückfragen bereit